and i said to you that the task was now
to
mush this together with your um
horizontal displacement equation with
respect to time
and eliminate t okay that's the goal so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to go
back up here
and i'm going to say this in fact let's
just let's just name this so i'm going
to call this equation 1.
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
grab this and i'm going to use this i'm
going to try and twist it into some
forms that make it easy
to substitute into here right so if i
make this
you know i'm going to say from equation
1
and it was so long ago in my working
that i think it is important to name it
and say where it's coming from
i've got this value for displacement and
remember i want to i don't want to just
like
simplify aimlessly right what i'm trying
to do is to eliminate this t
here so if i can get an expression for t
equals something
in terms of x that means i can get rid
of that t and then i also want to get
rid of this
t up here now in theory once i've got an
expression for t
here it can just go straight into there
but look this is a mess right it's got e
to the negative t on five i'm gonna have
to
evaluate there's gonna be index laws and
you can see i already have an e to the
negative t on five here so
i actually think this is gonna be even
easier to find without having to put
logs into exponentials of logs which
sort of cancel that anyway okay
so let's have a go on this first thing
i'm going to divide through by
75 that'll help me get closer to getting
this e to the negative t on 5
by itself and you can see it's like oh
this is not that complicated all i need
to do
is to add this term to both sides and
subtract this
from both sides that will get me the uh
e
to the negative t on five that i was
after
right so let's just go ahead and write
that add it to the left hand side
or to both sides rather and then i'm
going to subtract
that x175 so that's ready to go right i
can put that in
no further manipulation required so i'm
going to call this one
i got it from equation 1. so let's call
this 1a
i need to go i need to press a little
bit further to get my straight
expression for t
so if i take logs of both sides that
will give me
negative t over 5. it's going to be log
of
everything on the right hand side like
so
and then i'm just multiplying both sides
by negative 5 right so that will give me
t
equals this and i notice that when i
have a look at this sum
you know what's going on in here right
that negative i can get rid of um one
less thing to worry about
because you know if you think about this
as 1 minus x on 75 as a single
fraction i can pop into that that's
75 minus x on 75.
so the reason i'm using this is the
power law with logs i can put that minus
sign
in i don't have to do this because i
also have a minus sign
here so let's see if i can use this i'll
call this
one b i'm just keeping in mind my log
laws whether they'll be simpler for me
okay so i'm going to substitute now 1a
and 1b
into my parametric equation
for y which is up here okay so i'll say
oops sorry not into oops it is e let's
put that back
substitute those into y
like so here we go y equals negative
400 all right here comes this one minus
x on 75
terms so i'm going to go 1 minus x on
75 and then let's see what i get here so
excuse me the minus 50 and the minus 5
they're going to come together to give
me
plus 250 plus 250
and then i'm going to get the log term
now so it's 75 minus
x on 75.
and then i've got this constant that i
got from the constant of integration
earlier so that's going to be plus 400.
now if you look closely that plus 400
has
a buddy right there's this negative 400
hanging out the front so conveniently
those things are going to cancel
with each other i'm just going to get
going to get
uh negative negative cancel 400 x on 75
400 x on 75. uh
it looks like there's a common factor of
25 there so i'm going to get
16 x on 3 if i'm dividing through
properly
and then i'm going to get this log term
right now i remember in my previous
working that i actually had this as a
minus 250 but that's okay
it's a fraction one way or the other so
whether you have it this way or you have
the reciprocal
in there you're going to get something
that looks like this
and you think is this it is this a
cartesian equation
well i've eliminated all the time
variables so that's
check is this equation going to give me
the projectile motion you probably don't
have off the top of your head
what a constant like a linear function
not a constant function
a linear function plus a weirder looking
log like this you probably don't have a
good sense in your head
of what that looks like so i wonder if
some of you are reflexively opening
desmos
already to see what this looks like
here's one i prepared
earlier so when you go ahead and take
the function
and you graph it this is what you get
and you can see i've also
domain restricted it to start from the
origin now when you have a look at this
it sure looks like a parabola doesn't it
which you should not be surprised by
it's still going to be roughly parabolic
but if i go ahead and shade based on
where that stationary point is
hopefully you can see there's just
enough asymmetry here that that that
green section there you cover more
distance horizontally
in the green section versus the purple
section um of course because you're
being slowed down
all the way and so this is kind of the
modification
to projectile motion that we get to do
as extension to students
because we can take air resistance into
account
uh one final note by the way off of this
uh one of the things i think is amazing
if you go back to
this model we started with a drag
coefficient that k
of one fifth right um but in that video
that we started with talking about the
mars rover landing right uh one of the
questions that it begs is kind of like
what if you have a different drag
coefficient
right mars has or objects on mars have a
different drag coefficient because
there's just less atmosphere
right if you went to somewhere like
venus you'd have a lot more atmosphere
right
so i can modify my values for k get
different
time equations different parametric
equations and then smush them together
and get a new cartesian equation so
just out of curiosity i went beforehand
and i tried out what would happen if you
get
k equals a third rather than a fifth
and when i did that you can see over on
the left hand side there
um that third equation down or the third
line down
and that's the equation that i got it's
very similar you've still got an x term
and you've still got this weirdo looking
log term
but when i reveal it and i just want you
to have a think right what would happen
if you had a greater a higher drag
coefficient what would you
anticipate would be the result make a
prediction
and then tell me if this matches what
you think
should have happened right you can see
here it hasn't gone
as far because there's more aerodynamic
drag being experienced
uh and so you can see it doesn't reach
as high uh and it lands well there's
35.8 or 8.9 ish
and that's 48 so it lands like 10 meters
or 13
12 13 meters shorter okay so this is how
they did all that modeling and knowing
that you know if we have a parachute
this big it'll slow us down
that much if we're on such and such a
planet with this amount of atmosphere
and i think it's amazing that the
mathematics can do that for us
so um i've sort of taken you down to the
wire i apologize for that i should stop
doing that but if you go over to the
calendar you will notice
a couple of different things and this is
actually really important to note
if you go over to canvas in fact i will
change the share over to that screen
because i want to point out to you
what i put on while you're working
you're going to see exercise 6f the
particular questions
are on the calendar but in the questions
that have been assigned
um most of the questions in that
exercise do not have air resistance
there's only two questions and i've
assigned both of them
that do include air resistance so what i
encourage you to do
is if all this projectile motion stuff
is like oh i can't remember how to do
this
go and try out those questions that will
sort of
revise excuse me your extension one
projectile motion for you
but the focus for us here in extension
two is the questions with
air resistance so since there's only two
which is a bit lame and what i've done
is you can see here other exercises um
this will help you
get a little more practice there's
plenty more questions there i haven't
assigned all of them
it's in the calendar but you're welcome
to do those and they'll give you a bit
more
consolidation for your skills last thing
before i
sign off i do want to point out this is
that video that i was alluding to which
i filmed earlier today
if you were not satisfied like i wasn't
satisfied in case you couldn't tell
on this step here uh where we went from
uh
this differential equation to then
saying ah of course it must be
exponential decay
with a shift uh if this step uh sort of
confused you
then please go ahead and have a look at
the video and it will explain
how exactly from first principles and
using calculus because that's where
about in mathematics not just assuming
stuff
you can see you don't have to just trust
me you can actually see the result
okay and yes i did i actually
thought it was a joke when i was um
younger like there's this diagram you
can see
of mars landers that yeah they don't
have parachutes right they just kind of
like
uh actually i think maybe they do have
parachutes but they're not the primary
mechanism they just let it bounce
um because they're like air resistance
is too high there's not enough
atmosphere to do the job
and we just flat out didn't have the
technology to make parachutes that could
do
what we wanted curiosity and since then
perseverance i think is that the more
recent one to do so i just think
again it's amazing that mathematics is
what helped us work all that out